我明知道他打这个结婚证不是真的要跟我结婚，
那我也要去打，
我特别想请你帮助我，
因为我现在的情况是二婚，
我八七年的，
37了，
然后我先生现在是比我小一岁，
这五年我认识他之后，
我就以前从来不负债，
我现在负债是360多，
接近400，
这么多钱花到哪里去了？
怎么欠这么多钱呢？
我原本是做销售的，
就是线下做销售，
卖卖产品的，
认识他之后，
他就让我转线上去做电商，
因为我有个儿子，
我离异有个儿子啊，
我儿子跟着我，
他就对我儿子很好，
然后我就很感激，
因为我儿子的生父对孩子并不是很关照嘛，
他就很喜欢孩子，
我就觉得我孩子得到父爱了，
然后我自己本身有皮肤问题，
她也是很关照，
缺爱的女人容易犯错，
真的，
然后就在一起了，
在一起之后呢，
他用我的身份办了营业执照，
那之后就有公司了嘛，
有公司了就开始做线上的，
甚至后面才半年左右吧，
第二年他就直接开始干工厂了，
就重工业了，
工厂的投入就很大，
但是他是没有钱的，
他其实是负债，
但是我并不知道，
我问过他，
我说你之前说你做生意失败，
那你现在外面还欠多少外债，
他说就5万，
但是后面我在一起的第二年的时候，
我发现可能50万都不值，
他是黑户。
反正认识他之后，
现在我不仅黑护，
我也被法院执行了，
他就让我贷款嘛，
就是温水煮青蛙那种，
从几万块钱到十几万，
20万，
后来我突然发现有80多万了，
我就自己一下子反应过来有80多万，
我就觉得有点慌了，
他说现在我们工厂经营不下去，
电商是个团队，
工厂是一个团队，
然后两边都在亏钱，
两天都要养人，
每个月的工资十几万，
那个时候不知道怎么办，
他说必须得解决，
不然的话，
那我们以前80多万都把打水漂了，
我不同意再去借钱的时候，
他就会这样说嘛，
啊，
有点危险，
但是我也不甘心就这样倒了，
就想把它做起来。
然后我在深圳有套房子，
不大，
但是当时能抵押贷款70%的话，
能拿到156万，
出来就贷了156万，
我当时不贷，
不想贷这个钱，
后面他因为一套理论说服了我，
他说的是把这个钱贷出来，
公司运作最多20万，
可以先运作资金转动就可以，
剩下的钱拿去到一个广州一个比较。
就是偏远的地方买一套房子，
我们工着这样子相当于多了个资产，
但是钱一出来之后，
银行是告诉我说不可以拿这个贷款去买房子的，
他就跟我讲，
那就拿到店铺去滚一圈去把这个钱打散再收回来嘛，
但是一进到这里，
店铺是整的进去的，
几十万几十万进去的，
出来就不是整的，
因为你是你一单客单价才100多，
几十块，
这样的客单价收回来就散的，
每次要结客户的账单，
结结供应商的货款，
结工资，
这样一搞，
那个钱出来就没了，
直接就没了，
然后就100多万就下去了，
后来就啊这我自己是主播自己来拨，
他一开始做生意就框子搞得很大，
重现出工作室，
以前的工作室还在，
再加上那时候每天卖七八百件衣服，
就是每件每件衣服也是亏损的，
然后这里又亏了，
可能八九十万就一直在亏，
就这些年我就发现没有收入一直在亏，
而大家看到的那些光鲜亮丽都是我用钱带出来的，
我后面发现中途我所有给他的钱都不是在他的账上，
是在我的名下出出去的营业执照也是我的名字，
他说他是黑户，
就不能打结婚证嘛，
就这些都是在婚前发生的，
他有个女儿，
我也在养着嘛，
就我带着，
就从我的贷款已经贷干了，
我连房子什么都进去了，
已经没有，
再贷的时候就发现他脾气比以前越来越大，
我也管不了他什么事情，
也不能说上什么话，
我想问老师帮我解决的问题是现在，
其实一直以来这些年家里真正能在家用用。
的钱是很少的，
几乎是没有钱用，
我们有一个店铺的钱，
就是一百两百的这种到我手上，
而且是隔个几天一百两百到我手上，
这样子的一个家庭生活开支，
他都会查我的价，
他说你那3000块，
这样算下来，
一个月都拿了3000块给你了，
钱去哪里了？
我以前从来没有过这样的日子，
我一下子啊，
很接受不了，
这不是我用到哪里去的问题，
家里有老人，
他妈妈在啊，
有小孩，
我们要吃早餐，
要什么这个基本的开支，
去年的时候他就给我去打了个结婚证，
孩子读书，
为了他的孩子读书吧，
对对对，
因为他要在深圳读书，
是我要求的，
因为我跟他没有结婚证，
我心里想着这么多钱，
他一句话叫你滚就是分手了，
那我就要承担这么多，
我也害怕，
我明知道他打这个结婚证不是真的要跟我结婚，
那我也要去打，
现在相互的关系就是很紧张，
随便一个事情就能争吵，
现在这个男方的心理状态是什么呢？
第一，
他自己是个黑户，
所以他就无所谓破罐子破摔嘛，
第二，
他的女儿也已经上学了，
有上学的资格，
而现在你呢，
第一你负债三四百万，
第二你还有个儿子，
儿子成绩也不是很好，
所以现在你对他来说完全是负担，
这我我想过，
这个问题是你那套房子后来是现在那资产保权的状态不能赖你的，
这个房子被执行已经成为一个既定的不可挽回的事实了。
那房子被执行了之后，
大概能抵掉多少债务，
还剩多少债务？
呃，
应该有260万以上，
他进黑名单，
他身上的债务是多少，
你知道吗？
50万，
除了那个50万，
这个知道就是欠银行的事，
OK,
你那的时候还有260万在业务链上还有欠债，
还欠了多少？
100多万，
这个100多万呢，
就是说没有名义说是我的或者他的，
因为做生意是他去对接，
但营业执照是我的，
公司是你的，
股权是你的，
但这个公司如果说是正常的交了这个注册资本金的话，
那是公司欠钱没交，
他那边做是以个体户做的，
如果是以个体户做的的话，
那还是你欠钱，
因为个体户的营业执照是你，
个体户和你是一个绑定的关系，
等于是就算房子被抵掉了，
你的外债还有300多万，
是这么一个情况，
嗯，
我给你算完这个账了之后啊，
接下来我要给你讲的是什么啊，
接下来我要给你讲的是，
哎呀，
最坏最坏的结果，
房子没了，
我上黑名单了，
然后这个公司也经营不下去了，
我作为一个有直播能力的主播，
我去打一份工，
我去给别人当主播卖东西，
可能一个月能挣个8000一万的，
因为这个主播工资还是可以的，
那么你和你的孩子的生存是没有问题的，
为什么没有问题呢？
我可以去给他当主播的时候就给他说好了，
对吧，
你给我发钱的时候发现金也好，
或者直接发到我儿子名下也好，
你理解这个逻辑不理解啊？
我想告诉你的是，
无论如何，
只要你自己的本事还在，
你带着你的孩子还能继续生存下去，
但是你老公这一头的话，
你自己要去判断，
判断什么呢？
这个人到底是不是有能力，
如果说他自己把自己折腾成黑单，
又把你折腾成名单了，
是不是可以？
呃，
得出一个结论就是他的能力是配不上他的野心的，
如果说他的能力配不上他的野心，
像这样的男人，
你跟他过日子是不可能有好日子过的。
我说句难听点的话，
就算有一天有个天上的馅饼砸到他手上，
让他挣着钱了，
你日子照样不好过，
为什么？
我我知道啊，
因为在这个过程当中，
已经消磨了他对你的愧疚，
因为他把你的钱亏了，
他把你送上黑名单了，
你一定心里是有怨言的，
你一旦心里有怨言，
他那一头的话，
他就不高兴。
他刚开始的时候，
如果有良心的人呢，
或许会有一点点愧疚，
但是日子长了之后，
变成愧疚，
就会变成逃避，
到最后会变成恨和才智。
就算有一天他成为千万富翁了，
你照样被甩，
我心里面能感觉到，
如果哪天他有钱了。
跟我也没啥关系，
所以你现在需要做的就是给自己做最坏的打算，
就是做好这样的心理准备，
我就可能这辈子就在黑名单上待着了，
但我也得好好的活着，
我不能说我上了黑名单我就得去死吧，
我是我差点做了这个事情，
肯定想就是龙飞姐今天跟你连麦最有意义和价值的地方，
因为我也上过黑名单，
我也欠过债，
林林总总加起来的话也是几百万的债，
我那个时候就想，
如果说我没有这个能力还这个债的话，
假设我一辈子都在黑名单上待着的话，
我要不要好好活下去，
我要我要好好活下去，
因为我上黑名单这个事儿就跟你上黑名单似的啊，
不是我借了别人的钱不还，
我背着个良心债，
我上的黑名单，
我上黑名单完全是属于比如我是合伙人啊，
我要给人家承担连带责任，
或者我给人家签了担保，
我才上的黑名单，
同样的道理，
你这头不是因为你故意坑谁，
你借谁的钱不还，
你上黑名单是你被人坑了，
你上的黑名单我们至少是不被良心债的。
其实家里现在已经到了什么地步，
就是说难听点，
有的时候可以够钱买菜，
有的时候连这个都不够的状态，
但是他在外面还是要继续，
就是我是大老板的形象，
然后去就是交流，
他说我要向上睡觉才有生存能力，
就这样子，
然后呢，
这段时间他回家去搞房子去了，
去建房。
子，
然后说看始看风水的先生跟他讲，
说她要生个孩子才可以盖那么大的面积，
所以他前两天要求我说这半年之内要怀个孩子，
因为我和他之间一直是没有小孩子嘛，
你要清醒一点好吗？
像他现在这种情况，
自己背负着债务上了黑名单，
连累你背负几百万的债务，
债务上了黑名单，
他还有心思回去盖房子，
你觉得这样的人他真的能翻身吗？
他还有心思回去盖房子？
我的天呐，
他还要维持他的人设，
还要向上社交，
还要在外面看来他自己很风光，
就我觉得。
这他能发财，
我跟你说啊，
都是老天瞎了眼，
他能发财，
就是老天瞎了他才能发财，
他自己的姐姐也劝过我，
他说熬不下去就不要熬了，
他说不要为这样的人把命搭上，
他姐姐说这个话也是我想对你说的话，
无论如何啊，
姐妹就是你面对的最坏，
最坏的结果就是我现在我带着我的儿子，
我跟他分开了之后，
我身上虽然有这些债务，
都是欠银行的钱嘛，
也欠银行的钱人，
银行也不会说天天上门来堵你吧，
也不会天天来拿什么东西威胁你吧，
我也我有期什么的，
不至于对不对，
其实我也是想问的就是这个债务可以相互分配吗？
就是我比如说这个债务我们一个人一半，
我也是，
或者是怎么样，
这个债务如果你和他签一个夫妻财产约定书啊，
写明白，
这个债务是用于了他的事业经营当中，
只不过是借用了你的名义来办这个营业执照，
所以这个债务呢，
最终男方是愿意承担所有的债务的，
你要有这么一个东西在的话，
对你来说就相当于还有一个希望在，
这个希望在于什么呢？
就是老天真的瞎眼了，
他哪天真的发财了，
他把自己的债务也还清了，
并且他有余额了，
好，
那个时候你可以去打官司告他，
让他还你钱，
得等到那个时候，
那有点难。
如果他愿意，
他现。
那如果说什么都愿意的话，
你就让他签一个先放那儿，
万一老弟你瞎了眼呢，
那之前他签了一个那个房子的时候，
如果房子被法院执行了，
或者是就是没有因为他借借钱这个事情没有了，
他会赔250万，
或者是买一个同等价值的房子，
这个承诺书有用吗？
我觉得这个承诺书可能执行起来会比较困难，
执行起来会比较困难是在于什么呢？
可能到时候你们又不是夫妻关系了，
对不对？
他签订的时候，
我们就不是夫妻关系签的，
就当时签这个关系的时候也没写明白，
说这个房子是你借给他的，
就是这个房子卖了，
钱是你借给他用，
他去用于经营的，
其实最好的我认为比较稳妥的表述就说这些钱都是你借给他个人的，
用于他个人经营的，
你只是帮他出了个名，
挂了个名而已，
然后这些债务应该由他个人来承担的。
你最好是找个律师吧，
找个律师线下给你先起操，
好让他签字，
就你的意思是他这个状态，
还有我和他在一起，
包括我的孩子，
其实我们两个人都能，
我也能感受到，
我孩子也是很压抑的，
就是她是很大男子主义的，
甚至来了个客人，
我作为一个女人是不可以多说话的，
对，
安分守己，
如果多说话，
他觉得我破了他的局啊，
我说句难听点的话啊，
像你老公这样的人特别典型很多，
但是像你那么容易上当的女的更多，
像你老公这样的人，
她是非常会表演的，
特别善于表演，
特别善于去给别人提供一个情绪价值，
她为什么能忽悠那么多老板，
对，
为什么能忽悠你，
让你看，
给你画很多大饼，
让你看到美好的未来，
是因为他特别擅长这个，
他就算成功了，
你日子照样不好过，
我想也是，
主要他性格现在也是很可怕呀，
就是那种像个抱竹一样，
你根本不知道任何时候突然一下，
哪天他就给你爆棚了，
你一定要理性一点啊，
别到时候又再夸再生个孩子，
到时候你一个人带着两个孩子，
你可能就真的就没什么活路了，
我是不敢的，
一直都不敢一要的，
好吧，
嗯，
谢说他这个老公真的很典型，
有多少人你的爸爸就跟刚才的这个连麦的老公是一样的，
或者你的兄弟啊，
或者。
你的老公就跟刚才连麦的这个呃姐妹遇到的人一样，
就是在外面看来的话，
觉得他口若悬河，
上知天文，
下知地理，
待人接物非常的就是到位，
一个酒桌上的话，
他能把每个人都照顾的高高兴兴的，
面面俱到的，
各方面都照顾的很好，
就在外面一看的话，
觉得这个人哇，
好有能力啊，
他又认识了一个亿万富豪了，
又认识一个开上千万车子的兄弟了，
这样的人真的特别多，
但他内心深处的话，
可能。
就是说他实际上的能力和自己内心深处认为自己的能力的话，
相差十万八千里，
就这样的人，
你让他真干了什么事儿，
你让他认真研究一下，
这个合同该不该签啊，
这个门脸儿在这个位置，
人流量够不够，
对吧？
这个收入和支出怎么才能打平？
给员工开工资的话，
应该按什么比例，
给员工就是设奖励的话，
应该按什么规则，
你真让他落到实处来管这些的话，
完全不懂，
就是他的能力永远是配不上她的野心和她心目中那个自己的样子，
跟这样的人啊，
去生活去结婚的话是灾难，
他一定是灾难，
而且他永远不觉得自己有错，
他就算把刚才那个姐妹都已经害成黑名单了，
他也不会觉得是自己有错，
他任何时候的话，
要么就是你不问我对吧，
要么就是你说了什么话破了我的场，
要么就是你表现的不好，
才这个合同才没谈下来，
要么就是你的孩子今天惹我生气了，
所以我今天出去了之后不顺利，
一定是你的错，
他不会有错，
很典型特别典型的一个形象，
就他生意做的不好，
他亏钱了，
那都是你，
是因为你啊，
不带财，
不忘他，
所以跟这样的人是没有办法白头到老的，
你越早一步看清这样的人的真实的嘴脸，
你越早一步逃离，
那你就越早一步接近幸福，
逃离苦难。